as we've mentioned before it's his first
in studio in Los Angeles appearance for
this man so I want to give him the
proper introduction he's a Pro Football
Hall of Famer Super Bowl champion Super
Bowl MVP Walter Payton Man of the Year
Award winner by way of the Northern Iowa
University and the Amsterdam Admirals as
well getting set to call on Westwood won
the Saturday night divisional playoff
game between the Rams and the Cowboys in
between two different NFL gameday
mornings none other than Kurt one
everybody what do you think that was
pretty good and you got all the love in
there father grandfather there you go
grandfather to of to of to yeah yeah
yeah got a little grandson that came
about four months ago so how great is
that right oh my gosh did you get to
hand them back right exactly I mean
they're there almost every day but then
yes you can bring ice cream at eight
nine o'clock at night and then do that
we just did it the other day of course
makes ice that makes poppy I'm poppy it
makes poppy their favorite so yeah I do
that okay so let's get into the the
games this weekend let's start with the
Rams and the Cowboys because I can't
wait for your your piece on game day
morning you with McVeigh and golf yeah I
asked this question of Charles Davis our
one your level of confidence in golf
going into this game against the hot
boys would be would be what Kurt what's
it I have a lot of confidence in Jared
Goff but I will say that I think a lot
depends on the guys in front of him I
don't think his forte is when he's
getting quick pass rush and getting the
ball out of his hands quickly what I
love about him is when they do their
play-action and his second-level throws
his ability to get the chunk throws in
the big plays I think he's you know
almost as good as anybody in the
National Football League at doing that
but you know that's where the dilemma is
right there offensive line struggle they
got some older guys up there struggled
down the stretch
the hot boys coming to town that's what
they're all about is pressure on the
quarterback disrupting the quarterback
but I do like Jared Goff I feel really
good about where the Rams are gonna be
after this bye week second time around
with golf and McVeigh in the playoffs I
like their chances okay and Gurley is
his readiness is the key here right I
mean cuz that's that's how you get the
pressure off of golf and you know that's
how you get the big plays is they are
they play action more than anybody in
the league and so you have to start with
running the football and I mean even if
we watch the game last week against
Seattle is that Seattle didn't have a
lot of success running it but when did
they have success play action right when
they got those linebackers and the speed
of the Cowboys defense they want to
attack everything and they give you some
second-level throws it's what the Rams
do better than anybody so to me that is
the area to watch in this game is not
just rush yards but the ability to get
those guys to pull up and then Jared
Goff hitting over the top of those
linebackers the big play and the Cowboys
know this so what what's their
adjustment do you think coming into this
game well I mean I don't know if you
have a huge adjustment is that you still
have to stop Todd Gurley first that that
is the goal and so you have to stop the
run and hope like against Seattle last
week they don't make that many big plays
or your guys on the back end make up for
it but you can't play tentative against
Todd Gurley he is a mean you've seen him
in person when you look at him from the
waist down I mean it is it man that
comes down here he comes downhill hard
he's not easy to tackle so you have to
attack it but you got to get some
negative plays you got to keep him
behind the sticks you got to get Jared
golf to hold the football so those guys
can come after him
but yeah Dallas knows this and so we
talk about it every week the formula for
the Cowboys play good defense run the
football and keep it a one-possession
game to me is how they win this game I
don't think they're gonna score with
them I don't think this is gonna be a
blowout for the Dallas Cowboys
they have to keep it close and then hope
their young quarterback can can make
more plays down the stretch and so Kurt
Warner here on the Rich Eisen show of
all your vast experiences of what you've
been able to put out there and obviously
get into Canton because of it
I mean it's difficult to ask you what
well what makes a quarterback struggle
in his first playoff opportunity since
obviously we all know what you did with
yours right but golf did last year and
Hopi as you said it's his second time
around you've got mahomes trying to be
the only quarterback who's not been in
the playoffs before to win his first
playoff game of him own three last week
what what do you make of of what goths
able to do now that he had last year and
what mahomes will be able to do it
without having done it before well I
think there's a couple factors and first
you look at Jared Goff and Jared Goff is
built as a drop back quarterback very
much like I was so I believe the start
of this game is going to be crucial is
you can feel pressure when there's one
thing you kind of hang your hat on I've
got to be able to get back in the pocket
and hold the football and make throws
down the field things didn't start well
for him last year and they could never
really get out of their own way in that
game and he struggled so I believe how
they start will determine a lot of how
Jared golf plays specially because you
know you try to ignore it but people
have talked down the stretch he hasn't
played very well he's not playing his
best football going into the playoffs so
you feel and hear that pressure the
different thing about Patrick mahomes to
me is that he's got more hats that he
can put on
he's not just a drop back guy that has
to stand in the pocket and throw down
the field he's a playmaker and if
everything's not going great in the
pocket he'll run out of the pocket and
he'll throw a 45 yard laser on a rope
and that can change the complexion of
the game so I think he's got more to
work with then a Jared Goff deer golf
needs more things to go right for him
then Patrick mahomes does to have a good
game and so I do believe Patrick Holmes
is gonna come out and play like he's
played all year and have a great game
the question is can they get enough help
to beat a really hot Colts do ya the
Colts are really hot man well what's
happened with them what can you pinpoint
what what has happened with them I mean
I think the biggest I mean obviously we
know Andrew Luck has played great but to
me this is all about their offensive
line I mean their offensive line going
back and watching the tape against the
Texans last week I mean JJ Watt you
David they didn't even get close to
Andrew
the entire game and it's not just
Quintin Nelson I know we want to talk
about the draft pick he's been great but
it's really across the board they are
playing really really good football and
when you watch this team when they run
the football and protect the quarterback
they win which they've done a lot
especially down the stretch when they
don't do that very well they lose and so
you got a couple good pass rushers for
the Chiefs defense when you say they
don't have much going for them on
defense but they get rush the passer
they can get after Andrew Luck and that
to me is where this game is gonna be won
and lost offensive line of the Colts
against that defensive line of the
Chiefs and of all the tape that you've
watched Kurt Warner the best matchup for
a team this weekend when you see your
everything just look at all four of them
there's eight teams which team do you
think out of the eight teams it's like
you know what they've got the best
matchup for them to succeed in
divisional playoff weekend I'm going
with the Saints
I believe the Saints too they played him
once beat him by almost 40 had their way
big plays across the board in the dome a
bye week for Sean Payton and Drew Brees
against the team that they're seeing for
a second time I know Nick Foles has been
incredible and that team has turned it
around with him but if there's one team
that I think has the best chance to come
out of this weekend with a victory I'm
saying the Saints yeah it's interesting
you let's talk about foals a little bit
because a lot of people are comparing
what we're seeing from him to your
ascension your story that you can't make
up you know I'm sitting on my set my
chair and game day morning so I can see
your reaction to when people bring this
up Mariucci brought that but you can
make a movie out of this sort of thing
and the look you kind of gave him was
like you know I mean where's the Kurt
Warner story you're not working on it I
could see what's going on in your head
at the time you know the Kurt Warner
story's been in my making it's not easy
to do but Falls you you you can clearly
see though the the lines that are being
drawn what was going on in your mind
back in 99 that you think he's actually
at play with foals right now do you
think I think the biggest thing is that
nobody knows what you feel about
yourself or nobody knows the
circumstances you were in his people
always look at my story like you say
it's a movie you know it sat on the
bench for
years got cut worked in a grocery store
played away all that stuff but I look
back and tell people the funny thing is
why I kept going and believed that I
could you know do what I did in the NFL
was because every time I played football
I was successful one year in college
Player of the Year in our you know
conference you know I played three years
in arena football was the best
quarterback in arena football played one
year in Europe best quarterback
statistically in Europe that one year so
every time I had played I knew I could
be successful the problem was nobody
else knew that so when they saw me
they're like who is this joker he was he
was talking shelves there's no way he
can be any good but in my mind it was
like you're crazy I mean I know I can
play give me an opportunity put me
between the lines and I'll show you and
I really believe that's what goes on in
Nick Foles his head is that people want
to look at him you know for different
things and you know they got a chance
with the Rams and it didn't work out or
now he's a backup he can't cook and I
think he just basically says I can play
football I know I can play football and
everybody else wants to write a
different narrative but just go back and
look when I've played I've been very I
mean what 27 and to you know his first
run with Philly I mean you don't just
fall into 27 touchdowns and two
interceptions over that period of time
then he wins the Super Bowl last year
and we're still saying the same thing
well yeah but he's still a backup right
I mean but I just think that's the
parallel is I believed I could play the
game put the ball in my hands and I
could do what I've always done and I
believe Nick Foles says the same thing
to himself yeah and that's why I think
that's that's a powerful potent metric
that is an intangible obviously but you
think just because the Saints have seen
him before it's a week off it's that
building
yeah cetera et cetera and I think
they're the best better team you know
and I even think Chicago was the better
team last week outside of the
quarterback position I thought Nick
played well in the moment
and although Mitch made some great
throws down the stretch he missed some
opportunities early in which I think
they could have put that game away this
time around drew doesn't miss those
opportunities very often and in that
building with those fans like I said
with a
to really prepare yeah I just I think
there's too many big plays out there for
the Saints with the playmakers they have
that I just think this is gonna be
really really hard but let's just say
the defense of the Philly is really
what's carried is much we want to talk
about fools the defense has been what's
carrying them 18 points a game since
Nick Foles took over do you think that
happening in the dome I don't see that
happening in the dome I mean there's
gonna be 30-plus on the board for for
the Saints now will really get to see
Nick Foles in the magic can he out score
Drew Brees
and you saw how Sean Payton brought in
the trophy and and $200,000 in cash I
did not see it but I don't hurt but I
did so what what's the most off-the-wall
motivational tool a coach has ever used
with you like did Vermeil must doubt
$200,000 yeah I never saw anything like
that
and that's a good one I don't remember
anything really crazy that anybody has
done you know he brought in Joe Frazier
one time to speak Vermeil did Vermeil
brought in smoke and Joe yeah to speak
to us one time I remember and one thing
that I remember maybe more than anything
else is kind of getting us ready was how
we long came and talked to our team in
99 and he talked to us and gave the
speech about how when he was a rookie he
came in and they went to the Super Bowl
and you know he was kind of like this is
easy this NFL said we're gonna be in the
Super Bowl you know the rest of my
career and then he looked at as it goes
I never went back and I think that was
the the one motivating thing that really
stuck with me like you realized you know
and we had a great team there in st.
Louis with the greatest show on turf and
all that talent we won one Super Bowl
and we were fortunate to get back to two
but you know just to when you think you
could keep this thing together and you
can run and you can get all these
opportunities
I mean Drew Brees I think is a great
example of that right I mean he's done
everything you could possibly do in this
game he's been at one Super Bowl in his
entire career and that to me was
probably the greatest motivator for me
is don't miss this opportunity you've
got a great chance right here whether
it's to get $250,000 or whatever I think
it's a player you go
these things are tough to come by we've
got another prime opportunity to do that
if I'm drew brees or the Saints and that
to me was what motivated me more than
anything Kurt Warner here on the rich
eyes and she'll ask him the poll
question even though I know how he's
gonna answer it but I go for it anyway
Kurt what's QbD you want to see get
their first Super Bowl ring golf dak
Patrick mahomes Andrew Luck Philip
Rivers yeah oh man I always say that I
think everybody should have the
opportunity and be it a quarterback
every quarterback should have the
opportunity to play and win a Super Bowl
but I mean come on Philip Rivers I mean
I how do you not with all that he's done
and again the quality of person that he
is is is what I love so much about
Philip Rivers and he does it right and
he competes in he's been fun to watch
and he's played it you know the highest
of levels for so long yeah I want to see
Philip have that opportunity to compete
in that game you know when I sat down
with him when we you know run the
interview numerous times but you know
just asked him you know how often do you
think about that because you know when
you're growing up in in front yard you
think about winning the Super Bowl and
you think about and what am I gonna say
or what am i and he goes I still dream
about that I still watch guys every year
going okay what did they say on the
podium like what am I gonna say and so
you know it's just like a little kid
going man I just want that moment to be
able to say whatever it is I say it have
my moment to be on that podium and you
know of all those guys I hope they get
to experience it one day but if I had to
pick one I'm picking Philip Earl he's
got a win in Foxborough yes yes he does
got a win in Foxborough yeah and and and
I know the the Chargers all year long
have been winning in spots do you don't
you don't expect him to win Pittsburgh
being one the short week Thursday night
in Kansas City being just another and
that wasn't being played in the middle
of the summer either I mean it was a
chilly night we're expecting to see a
ton of cold weather we all know you know
you played most of your games inside of
a dome or instead of warm weather do you
consider this of the end of the trail
potentially you know I don't yet
because I really do believe this is one
of philip rivers best teams complete
teams that he's with and I believe that
the Patriots are down a notch I know
they're undefeated at home and you know
you know you know the scenario out in
New England it's tough to beat them but
I believe this is one opportunity where
they can be gotten the question to me is
as you mentioned the weather you know
cuz I say it all the time and I played
in domes I played in Arizona there is no
way to prepare in one week for weather
you know to prepare to play in snow or
to play in cold and get yourself
acclimated to that you know there's a
story that I hear kind of through the
grapevine we went out and played when I
was in Arizona we went out and played
New England one year and the night
before the game a bunch of snow dropped
and it was cold and our media people
their box was right next to the box for
the coaches of the New England Patriots
and maybe our many people said when the
coaches came up there they heard
high-fiving and cheering and all the
stuff going on from the box and this was
before the game even started and somehow
it got you know leaked out that the
reason they were high-fiving was because
when they looked down at the field all
their guys were out on the field warming
up all of our guys were over by the
heater huddling up trying to stay warm
like easy and they did they blew us out
they'd beat us by almost 40 in that game
and so that is the hardest thing is that
mentally you can be tough but you're
still cold
and I always say as a quarterback you
know we do nothing in a game right we
drop back seven steps and throw the
football so there's nothing to do to
stay warm when it's cold outside and so
sometimes you have to change your
routine you got to sit over by the
heater and it's just different and so if
the weather's decent I really believe
the Chargers have a chance to win this
game if the weather starts to drop or
there's any kind of elements you know I
think it's probably one that you can
chalk up for the patron again I'm part
of that group of I guess pundits or as
you said confidence right okay hundun
that believes the chargers are equipped
to do this they're equipped to do it as
I said they've been winning on the road
they've won in every time zone including
London yeah but they have to the
ultimate buds well they have to avoid
the Foxborough trap which is pre snap
penalties which is create you know that
third down penalty when you're just
about to get off the field or the
offsides to turn a Brady three third and
a into third and manageable the not
hopping on the loose ball when you could
have hopped on the loose ball I mean it
happens to almost every team that goes
into Foxborough in January not name the
Patriots yeah and those are the things I
mean if Anthony Lynn is that that's got
to be something you're constantly
pounding right I mean we're pounded but
I think it all stems back to the lore of
the Patriots at home is that there's so
much pressure to play perfect right like
I mean we can't make a mistake we can't
do anything wrong if we're gonna win
this football game here and ultimately
that that's what always happens for a
player when they try to press and push
and play perfect they make mistakes and
so how do you avoid that you know how
can you mentally push that I mean you're
Philip Rivers right and what's he gonna
hear you know I mean I think back to the
Chiefs week right they said hey the
streak of however many games that the
Chiefs have beat you know and then he
came out afterwards he goes hey I tried
to deny that streak all week long and
tried to convince myself it wasn't there
I mean what's he gonna hear all week
you've never beaten a Tom Brady led
Patriots you've never beaten him you
haven't beaten him and so he's got to
hear that all week and so somehow
someway you got to shove that back
behind you where you just tune it out
and go hey it's just another game but we
know it's so hard to do that you know
the stakes
everybody's talking not just about that
but they're talking about is this Philip
Rivers last chance best chance to get to
us I mean there's so many things going
on in this game and then you've got to
go out and push it all out and play a
really good football game without
mistakes in Foxboro against Tom Brady on
the other sideline
it sounds easy to talk about that stuff
much more difficult to do okay and Irv
Irv is gonna I'm assuming herbs gonna be
in the building tomorrow night Dallas at
Ram's yeah you'll be calling the game on
Westwood one does that mean you're not
gonna pick the game on game day morning
because you're calling it on the radio
I'm picking the game okay yeah I'm
picking the game so then who do you
thinks gonna be in the Super Bowl
Superman champion champion sure game um
I believe the Rams are gonna win this
game
um I just uh you know when I get to the
playoffs sometimes I look at and go who
has more ways to win a football game
because I always believe you have to be
able to win different ways come playoff
time and you know Dallas is going to run
the football and Rams are very good at
stopping the run they're gonna play good
defense but the one thing the Cowboys
don't do is score a lot of points they
hardly ever score a lot of points to put
them you know put a game away early they
played I think 13 games this year
including the playoffs that were one
possession games thirteen of them and so
this is gonna be a close football game
and with the Rams ability to get big
plays and score points even if they
don't play their best game I think
they're gonna be in there at the end and
have a way I have a chance to make plays
and I think they have enough playmakers
but I could also see this thing getting
away from the Cowboys and you know and
the Rams winning it fairly bay so Rams
at Saints based on your previous thought
about the matchup for the Saints and in
the AFC Man in the AFC I'm going with
the Chiefs I think the Chiefs again
until they show me that somebody can
stop them
I mean 26 points is the least amount of
points that they've had all year long
and that was against the Arizona
Cardinals everything else is 29 30
they're gonna find a way to score points
as much as I like the Colts I'm going
with the Chiefs at home and then the
other side I really think this one is up
for grabs
I'm not actually even sure who I'm
picking yet you know it's always hard to
go against the Patriots yes it is but if
things are even if Sunday morning dish I
may be one of those guys Georgia or
charger ish that goes Philip Rivers and
the Chargers in this one I want to see
how the weather plays out but but that
one to me I think has an opportunity
be really really close if the conditions
allow you know it to be more of an even
footing for football teams and before I
let you go Kurt Warner I want to give
you this platform because I'm always
appreciative of you coming on the show
certainly here in person and I have
nothing but love for you and your
awesome wife Brenda let's talk about
treasure house let's talk about down in
down in Arizona first one in Arizona
what is it for people who might not know
it and how can they get involved so
treasure house is a community living
facility for young adults with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities as you know and some that
close to me know that my oldest son
suffered traumatic brain injury when he
was four months old and it was told he'd
be lucky to live and sit up and he
exceeded all the expectations and
graduated high school but it was after
high school where we're kind of going
now what what's next for him he's got a
purpose he's got skills you know we look
and see disabilities
I look at Zach and see abilities all
kinds of abilities just has to be tapped
in the right way and so we went out and
said let's let's figure out how to build
a place where young men and women and
families like ours their children can
live have the independence that they're
allowed also have the supervision the
supervision that they need but can be
pushed into the community and can grow
and can thrive and can have a purpose in
life and so we build our first treasure
house it opened up about four months ago
and I was just there last week and we've
got eight or nine residents now as we're
continuing to build up we've got a few
more coming after you know in the next
couple weeks but it's just starting to
buzz and they're starting to get out
into the community and it's fun to hear
parents talk about the ability to dream
for their child with disabilities and
it's fun as a parent to watch my child
thrive in a way that you know that I
never imagined a decade ago and so
that's what treasure house is and you
can go to treasure house org to get
involved we've got different fundraisers
that we do we can make a donation you
can find out you know what we're doing
because we want to get this right and
then we want to take it around the
country and around the world so every
family has that opportunity to
do that so treasure-house tada work is
where you can go and appreciate you
giving me man talk about Curt my
pleasure
you and Brenda are awesome your family's
awesome and and I can't wait to see you
later on at the end of on the awesome I
can't wait either thanks so what'd you
think of your first in-person experience
here yeah this is a pretty big garage
you got here I mean I you know I thought
maybe you were bringing me to your house
and I was gonna be assured in the front
door that I like it this is an operation
this is a machine HOD cast anymore it's
not a podcast well you know Kurt you've
been away a long time yeah you taking
that step up I like it
can I come back can I come back sometime
if you'd like okay very good
I don't know I mean you got a very busy
schedule you just said you're not even
gonna be in studio four championship
Sunday or do you know which one you do
an AFC or NFC sure yet I don't even know
depending I think on how it plays out
but just take a while be doing the show
from location so I'll be in one of those
stadiums probably when it's dark and
nobody's there look how we talk to you
guys all right at 13 Warner on Twitter
as well as Instagram Kurt I'll see you
back at the shop up the street in NFL
Network the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience